[Music]
[Applause]
14-time pro bowler and Amazon Prime
video analyst Thursday Night Football
Tony Gonzalez back on the program Tony
thanks for joining us let me ask you
what uh did you learn more about the
Lions last night or the Chiefs last
night
ah when I learned more about you know
what going into the game I actually had
the Lions win it because
no Travis Kelsey First Team all pro no
Chris Jones First Team all bro two of
the the best in the business you don't
have your dogs it's hard to win and the
lions are a good football team uh what
did I learn more about I I would
probably say the the lines though Dan
Campbell if you don't like Dan Campbell
there's something wrong with you the way
this guy coaches his energy uh he's got
those guys out there playing I love the
the second half adjustments that they
made the lions are good they're a
playoff football team I anticipate them
winning that division Aiden Hutchinson
coming on he's not TJ watt yet he's not
Nick Bosa yet but he's on his way uh
there's a lot of good things that you
that you saw in that Lions football team
last night how would you feel if you're
Patrick Mahomes today
well uh if no one Patrick and and what I
see in the you know that documented
quarterback the type of person he is
he's gonna be positive he's going to go
in there and tell those guys look you
need to catch the football I mean he was
throwing some good footballs last night
Kadarius Tony Sky Moore don't want to
get on those guys because Lord knows I
have my fair share of drops when I
played but those guys need to go out
there and and get that confidence back
because catching the football is just
confident so look it was a main game it
was Thursday night opening day of the
season I think these guys were just a
little nervous to be on that big stage
they can play football uh but Patrick
I'm I'm sure he's like hey Travis how's
that how's that knee feeling buddy I
need I need you back because because
they needed him last night I think if
they had Travis they'd win that football
game what do you say to Kadarius Tony if
you're his teammate
if I'm his teammate because remember I
don't know if you guys remember but my
second year in the league I led the NFL
and dropped passes uh it was the first
first year starting to start my rookie
year the second year I was the start
incident it's different when you're the
guy when everybody's counting on you the
nerves are there uh and the the
corrections that I made and what I would
tell cadarius and Skye is you need to
stay out and come before practice get
you 150 balls before practice
during practice when the defense is
going catch some more balls put your
chin strap on put your mouthpiece in get
game situation catch footballs after
practice is over everybody goes in you
need to stay your butt out there and
catch some more footballs catching is
just like a free throw jump shot you
just the more you do it the better
you're gonna be and I think right now
they probably went in there a little a
little overconfident a little over
prepared the NFL will humble you in a
second just like they are right now and
hopefully they get it together because
because we need those guys down the
stretch there is no body coming in here
anymore those are the guys caders Tony
is is gonna have to be that that guy
next to Travis Kelsey uh and we're gonna
need him down the stretch we're going to
get back to the Super Bowl yeah I
thought the big question with him was
going to be can he stay healthy not can
he catch a football but last night I
mean that's inexcusable we're talking to
Tony Gonzalez explain to me what Kelsey
does differently than say you do or what
Gronk did or you know you're a Hall of
Famer gronk's a Hall of Famer Kelsey uh
it seems to be doing something that
nobody else has done
yeah well you know what he does I love
how
such a great feel I mean he can find
those zones he can and him and Patrick
that that's special it's it's like that
Gronk Brady
special connection that these guys have
with each other where they can read each
other and know which each other's
thinking before they sometimes they even
know like Patrick knows what Travis is
going to do maybe before he even knows
that and when you have that that's rare
that is so rare uh and the way Travis
when he gets the ball in his hands after
he gets the ball in his hands I think I
I don't know if there's anybody better
uh in the NFL history that at the tight
end position of getting up field making
people Miss he's like Gumby out there
the way he makes people miss and gets up
there's not a big physical type run you
over Jeremy Shockey Grant type thing
it's just so we zigging and zagging and
getting through traffic and making plays
after he gets the ball in his hands I
love him for it and this is why you know
this this is the guy they're they're
doing great things Patrick Mahomes when
you have two Hall of Famers playing
together like that two first team Hall
of Famers you you're gonna you're gonna
create Magic uh and and I hope I think
next week when when Travis gets back
you're gonna see a a a 10 catch
performance over 100 yards this is why
those guys are unstoppable you can't and
then Andy recalling the place you just
you just can't stop him it's a it's an
unbelievable combination give me the
surprise team keep an eye out on
oh
surprise team I'm gonna go
I don't I would say Baltimore but I
don't think that's a surprise but I
think Baltimore is going to be a whole
lot better than what everybody thinks
but the Pittsburgh Steelers
Hall of Fame type coach Mike Tomlin
great coach I think Kenny Pickett with
George Pickens Deontay Johnson and we
have them twice this year on Thursday
Night Football so we get to see them up
close and personal uh Friar moose the
tight end had 63 catches last year Najee
Harris in the backfield uh defensively
TJ uh TJ watt high Smith had 14 and a
half sacks like I don't know why people
aren't talking about the Pittsburgh
Steelers a lot more than what they are
they're they're a dark horse team do not
be surprised if they make a playoff run
and a deep playoff run but obviously
it's Kenny Pickett and what he did last
year in the second half of the season if
and he's only going to get better uh I
think I think they're poised to go out
there and do some damage in this league
this year you're not wearing sleeves
today
you're sending a message today you got a
tank top on you got the guns okay uh
okay you didn't have tats when you
played did you
I did not I did not I got these after I
played and what what's the message
behind your attached that you're only uh
you're trying to sleeve one arm here
uh yeah that's what I got my whole I've
had my whole back done when I was
playing uh but uh yeah I got these you
know I gotta this is gratitude this is
uh you know it's a tiger I've always
been a big fan of tigers a little a hawk
for Independence and then the the tree
you know the tree the the Tree of Life
uh you can't you gotta have roots that
reach to Hell uh and and the tree that
reaches to heaven so it's a duality of
life you know this deep meaning stuff
you got tats Dan uh yeah a couple of
them
do you really yeah survive yeah what do
you got
uh Thug Life across my chest
um
I'm not surprised yeah but that's really
about me and my wife but uh yeah you
know just uh just a couple of you know
some father stuff
you know nothing too deep nothing you
know no trees or anything like that or
no no tigers or anything but just a
couple of them just little reminders
there you know the one on the back how
long that take you to do
uh it took um a whole off season
probably around 40 hours of work it it
was very painful uh I did that when I
think I was 28 years old
yeah it was time to get some new ones uh
we're talking to Tony Gonzalez he'll be
on Thursday night with uh Amazon Prime
14 time Pro Bowl uh looking back you
didn't wear gloves
uh as a rookie when did you change to
wear gloves and how much of a difference
was that for you
uh I think later that rookie year when
we played in December in in Kansas City
and the temperature was five degrees
uh him I couldn't feel my hands that's
what I put on gloves and and then I was
like I like these things you know the
gloves were different back then I didn't
like them originally because I felt like
you know the ball would slip out of them
uh but you see these gloves now you know
it used to be illegal you couldn't you
couldn't spray that tax stuff I remember
seeing that stuff in the 70s and 80s
um now you those gloves are incredible
you see these one-handed catches not
taking away anything from some of these
receivers but you put on some of those
gloves Dan you might be able to go out
there and catch some footballs
well I asked Jerry Rice about you know
because rice I said you know are they
that much of an advantage I mean I don't
know if Jerry wore gloves early in his
career but he did wear gloves I think
later how much of an advantage is it
performance enhancing wearing those
gloves
absolutely absolutely
those gloves that they have the the
sticky without even yeah materials but
that ball just sticks sometime uh to it
so for sure all right if you're a
receiver not wearing gloves I think
you're just being
dumb hey put some gloves on who's the
best tight end of all time
uh now you want The Confident answer or
you want the uh the political answer
which one I want the real answer
ah
well I I think confidently speaking I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna always think
me because that's what you gotta have
uh now if you want to go politically I
think you can make a case for a couple
guys uh I think Gronk I think Travis
Kelsey
uh I think us three are up in that
conversation right now uh and I like I
think if kiddo could get back because
what Kittle does
is he's a hell of a blocker as well you
gotta let's I don't want to lose the
traditional tight end a lot of these
tight ends coming in they don't block
anymore maybe because they don't have to
and that's fine just like you know stuff
happens the league evolves you don't
like running backs anymore it seems but
tight ends used to block a lot uh and
those throwback guys I'm a big fan
because that's what I had to do I had to
block a lot I blocked power my hand was
in the dirt I had to evolve that
position so okay can I please go on the
slot can you put me out there as a wide
receiver and thank God I had office of
coordinators that would do it and now
you see everybody doing it but nobody
did that before who was the best
basketball player you played against in
college
ah
I think
Tim Thomas was really good uh I actually
played against him he was at Villanova
uh who else uh Jerry stack uh Jerry
Stackhouse
uh their little abandoned Brothers
really good remember Charles and Ed
O'Bannon those guys are really good uh I
think they yeah those guys right there
but did you at what point did you
realize I can't play basketball at the
next level
uh and I don't know if I ever realized
that
Miami Heat yeah I played a lot of
basketball a lot of people don't know
this but I played a lot of basketball
during the off season that was kind of
my off season work and when I say play
basketball I'm not talking at your Rec
Center at the YMC I'm saying I played in
NBA leagues I played in The Drew League
out in La so I guess if you from that
standpoint I played against you know I
played with Klay Thompson on his team I
played against Beau out I played with
magic against Magic Johnson with uh
with uh God who was on my team anyway I
played in the summer I played out I
tried out for the Miami Heat when Pat
Riley was the coach Eric's poster was on
that stab yeah Stan Van Gundy was on
that staff I I there was 20 of us that
tried out they only kept 12 of us I made
the team I toured with the team during
the summer out in Miami uh played with
Quran Butler rasool Butler Mike James uh
it was it was fun so I know I could have
played in the NBA it's just I would have
averaged you know three points maybe
five rebounds but I wouldn't I probably
wouldn't have started for sure I think I
made the right choice yeah but you still
could have made a ton of money even
getting you know three points a game in
the NBA with the way they they pay
players
I always think about it I probably would
have made more money yes
as you know we are underpaid and Travis
Kelsey by the way we talk about Chris
Jones holding out
Travis Kelsey might want to start
holding out
he only makes 14 million dollars which
is a lot of money but comparatively
speaking to 1200 yards and 13 touchdowns
and 110 catches my man is underpaid yeah
we were joking that maybe he should just
hold out too with Chris Jones just to
say I mean what would you pay could you
pay him like 20 million dollars is he or
is he worth more than that
yeah he's worth more than that I mean
I'll tight ends I I went through this
when I was playing it's like hey wait a
second I had 102 catches last year over
a thousand yards on first female Pro and
they're like and the general managers at
the time Carl Peterson said tell him he
put his hands behind his head he's like
hey that's you're tied in I'm gonna pay
you like a tight end it's just a I
always I always tell I have banter with
traffic Travis is my guy I love him I'm
always like man 14 million When You Got
The Look Around The League at what some
of these other receivers are making it's
not even close he is not underpaid by a
million or two we're talking five six
seven ten million dollars underpaid this
guy is worth 25 million dollars a year
he is a baller and essential to that
offense but you know it's the it's your
position yeah hey uh great to talk to
you have fun on Thursday night always uh
always fun to catch up with you thank
you
yeah thanks for having me there
appreciate it Tony Gonzalez 14 Time pro
bowler and Hall of Famer Amazon Prime
video Thursday night football analyst